[Musique]
bienvenue en débat sur france 24 alors
que la guerre en ukraine est entré dans
son deuxième mois l'armée ukrainienne
aurait totalement repris le contrôle
dire pin dans la banlieue ouest de kiev
selon en tout cas le maire de la ville
par ailleurs les autorités ukrainiennes
s'inquiète d'une aggravation de la
situation humanitaire déjà
catastrophique à marioupol les
négociateurs russes et ukrainiens sont à
istanbul pour de nouveaux pourparlers un
des points des négociations portent sur
les garanties de sécurité
la neutralité le statut de
dénucléarisation de l'état ukrainien a
déclaré le président ukrainien dans les
médias russes alors quelles sont les
options diplomatiques volodymyr those
qui est il prêt à la neutralité que
signifie la neutralité justement pour un
état comme l'ukraine on viendra aussi
dans cette émission sur les déclarations
de joe biden joe biden qui a affirmé que
poutine ne pouvait pas rester au pouvoir
une déclaration rectifié par la maison
blanche et avant de vous présenter mes
invités ont fait tout de suite un point
sur le terrain avec notre correspondant
à kiev gulliver crack gulliver bonsoir
l'armée ukrainienne aurait donc
totalement repris le contrôle dire pin
c'est ce que dit le maire en tout cas
voilà c'est ce que dit le maire en tout
cas mais ils disent aussi que il va y
avoir des opérations de nettoyage dont
irbine que ce n'est toujours pas
possible d'y aller pour les civils 60000
habitants d'irbine pour la plupart ont
été évacués pour le moment il sera
encore interdite date
on vous a perdu gulliver gulliver craque
donc un qui revenait justement sur le
fait que hier pin avait été repris par
les ukrainiens toujours selon le maire
on va en discuter de cette situation en
ukraine avec mes invités j'ai plaisir
d'avoir mis côté l'amiral alain à col de
fibres soir ancien major général des
armées hauteur de le sel et les étoiles
et c'est aux éditions favre bienvenue à
vous en face de vous frédéric charillon
bonsoir professeur à l'université
clermont vern spécialiste de questions
internationales hauteur de guerre d'
influence les états à la conquête des
esprits c'est osé 10 odile jacob
bienvenue également avoue yves doutriaux
et tag est également avec nos bons soirs
ancien ambassadeur à l'ouest c'est eux
ancien ambassadeur adjoint à l'onu
professeur de géopolitique à
paris-dauphine bienvenus ils doutriaux
en face de vous et les nabots de chine
notre correspondante en russie
journaliste également à france 24 qui
nous fait tous les jours le vus de
russie bonsoir elena moussa alors qu'une
semaine de négociations je vous le
disais ce s'ouvre maintenant en turquie
au niveau des ministres des affaires
étrangères russe et ukrainien des
discussions qui ont été jusqu'ici jugé
difficile par les deux camps on va
revenir justement sur la déclaration du
président ukrainien et il a parlé de
garanties de sécurité de neutralité on
écoute tout de suite volodymyr et la sq
et
garanties concernant les garanties de
sécurité de neutralité et le statut non
nucléaires de notre état nous sommes
prêts à y aller
c'est le point le plus important c'était
le point principal pour la fédération de
russie aussi loin que je me souvienne et
si je me souviens bien c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont commencé la guerre amiral
alain cold fish contente on exactement
par neutralité qu'est ce que ça signifie
pour inscrire la neutralité on la
connaît en europe puisque on a quelques
pays neutre dans la suède et la finlande
qui sont des pays guerrier bien sûr donc
c'est un statut qui permet de vivre
confortablement et de se positionner
plutôt dans un camp occidental est pas
sûr que le président poutine soit tout à
fait d'accord avec cette perspective
mais ça veut dire qu'on renonce aux
armements où l'on prie mignard isation
ou par normal d'être alité la neutralité
la suède et la finlande pour ne prendre
que ces deux pays sont dp puissamment
armés mais qui ne font pas partie d'une
alliance d'un camp et qui décide à
chaque fois de leur sort contrairement à
l'autriche par exemple alors l'autriche
est volontairement j'ai pas citer parce
que oui mais faut le site est resté
parce qu'elle est juste avant les
différences voilà dans non non il n'est
pas sûr que le président poutine accepte
un statut de neutralité analogue à celui
de la finlande de la suède qui il s'est
vite calé dans le nord donc pour moi
c'était une ça fait partie de la
négociation possible du président aulas
qui je trouve que je suis pas
négociateur mais là il avance un petit
peu trop ses arguments mais ça c'est à
lui de voir avec poutine frédéric
charillon alors effectivement pour
revenir sur cette garantie de sécurité
neutralité ce statut dénucléarisé de
l'état ukrainien ukrainien on pourrait
pas justement avoir un statut à
l'autrichienne
com vient de dire l'amiral on sait pas
exactement ce qui est proposé ni ce que
l'univers poutine accepterait c'est que
ça peut être un statut de neutralité
absolue sans soient désarmés ou pas
désarmé là on prend des exemples de
l'union européenne ont forcément un
moment va se poser la question de
neutralité compatible avec une
possibilité de candidature à l'union
européenne ce qui va pas plaire
forcément beaucoup à moscou et puis
c'était vraiment neutre lorsqu'on
appartient à l'union européenne il ya
des pays neutres dans l'union européenne
au sens où ils ne sont pas membres de
l'otan ce qu'on a bien compris
aujourd'hui c'est que la russie ne veut
pas d'une ukraine qui puisse candidater
à l'otan et le président ukrainien a
déjà fait savoir à plusieurs reprises
qu'effectivement c'était un objectif qui
aujourd'hui serait difficile à tenir
donc il est peut-être prêt à discuter de
ça aussi après il ya les qui lui-même
c'est le régime actuel on a quand même
en face un pays la russie rien président
poutine qui est depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant parle de dé nazifié
le pays qui les traitent de tous les
noms de drogués et cédera donc est ce
que la neutralité porte sur le statut du
pays au sens international de ses
alliances etc ou est ce que pour moscou
ça voudra dire aussi un gouvernement
qu'il considérera comme neutre
c'est-à-dire certainement pas dans la
mouvance de l'actuelle elena justement
pour les russes la neutralité ça veut
dire en tout cas laisser des troupes au
moins stationné à dans le bon bah si je
puis dire alors on sait clairement ce
que veut la dîmière poutine vladimir
poutine veux-tu l'ukraine démilitarisé
c'est à dire qu'il n'a plus de pouvoir
de défense et qui n'a plus d'armée et
vladimir poutine veux-tu l'ukraine qui
s'engagent à ne jamais intégré l'otan
que dit en face volodymyr zelensky il a
accordé une interview très importante
hier à des journalistes indépendants en
russe une interview d'une heure et demie
qu'il fallait bien écouter parce qu'il a
dit je ne veux pas de centaines de
milliers de morts en ukraine dont je
suis prêt à discuter du statut de
neutralité avec le président poutine il
il entendrait par là qu'il serait prêt à
discuter du fait que effectivement
l'ukraine n'intègre pas l'otan mais ils
posent des conditions très claires il
dit il n'y aura de discussion et de
négociation possible qu'à partir du
moment où l'occupation est terminée
c'est à dire que l'armée russe cessent
d'envahir l'ukraine
pragmatique gérer ce qui par ce qu'il
dit en plus revenons aux positions
initiales celle d'avant le 24 février
sachant que l'armée russe a déjà envahi
l'ukraine dans les régions séparatistes
de lougansk de donetsk et qu'elle s'y
trouvait bien depuis 2014 n'en déplaise
à vladimir poutine qui dit qu' il n'a
jamais participé à cette guerre donc ce
que dit pour le dit mme higgins qui sait
que revenons aux positions de départ
d'accord vous avez annexé la crimée
d'accord vous avez envoyé dans basse
mais retourner y est on discute
éventuellement d'une possible donc on ne
sent pas que mon pays souffre que mais
que mes citoyens meurent par en
renonçant à l'est alors il ne l'a pas
dit mais en tout cas ils posent là les
termes d'une possible négociation juste
un mot justement cette interview et
l'ena elle n'a pas été diffusée elle a
été en fait ce sont des médias russes
mais elle a été diffusée que à
l'international pas en russie c'est cela
alors il y avait une blague qui
circulait sur les réseaux sociaux disant
que rose comme nador le gendarme russe
des télécommunications a interdit à des
médias qu'il avait déjà interdit de
diffuser une interview parce que les léo
hormis le journal kommersant les médias
qui ont participé à cette interview
c'était un chrono le rédacteur en chef
de la chaîne de télévision d'offres donc
toute la rédaction s'est exilé à
l'étranger suite au fait que le média a
été interdite c'est donc ils ces
interdictions sur interdiction interview
de zelensky totalement censurer les
médias qui l'ont interviewé interdit
donc c'est vous dire qu'on a que
vladimir poutine a peur que les russes
entendent ce que 10 seulement volodymyr
zelensky il du trio vous qui êtes
justement ambassadeur ancien ambassadeur
à l'onu l'organisation de la sécurité en
europe du point de vue de la sécurité en
europe est ce que des garanties de
sécurité est ce qu'elle est a
effectivement comme l'ukraine pourrait
être neutre dénucléarisé avec des
garanties de sécurité quelles pourraient
être les garanties de sécurité d'un tel
état c'est effectivement ce que demande
le président et le style il a bien
raison parce que si la neutralité c'est
resté sous la dépendance étroite de de
la russie soit il ya plus vraiment
d'ukraine état souverain indépendant
alors des accords qui prévoient une
sorte de garantie internationale
luis ça peut tout à fait exister
d'ailleurs l'eau a eu
pour elle pourrait le faire
d'une certaine façon si je prends juste
un précédent qui n'en est pas vraiment
la georgie quand il ya eu cette guerre
en 2000 2008 la russie a menacé
d'envahir la georgie à partir de
l'ossétie du sud et de l'abkhazie
jusqu'à la capitale puis si finalement
il ya eu cette médiation du président
sarkozy qui est allé à moscou elle est
ici et les russes sont revenus sur la
ligne de front antérieur et à ce moment
là c'est l'union européenne je change
d'organisation excusez moi c'est l'union
européenne qui envoyait des observateurs
qui ont été détachés le long de cette
ligne de contrôle entre la georgie
centrale et cette province
sécessionniste d'ossétie du sud un petit
peu comme laon nous parlons là l'instant
des provinces de donbass sécessionnistes
pour observer à un cessez le feu alors
c'est une forme de garantie temporaire
là il s'agit d'observer un cessez le feu
puisque dans un accord il y aura
plusieurs phases ce que demandent les
laves ski tout de suite c'est l'arrêt
des combats donc avoir des garanties sur
l'arrêt des combats alors après quand il
ya un statut futur peut-être une
neutralité et pourquoi pas une garantie
internationale on a parlé de l'autriche
tout à l'heure et vient dans la corde
1955 les quatre alliés enfin ancien
allié puisqu'on est en pleine guerre
froide c'est à dire des trois
occidentaux et l'urss ont apporté leur
garantie de sécurité à l'autriche et
l'autre étaient couverts par le
parapluie de l'otan sans appartenir à
l'otan en fait elle n'appartient pas à
l'otan donc n'est pas couverte par le
paradis de l'otan en revanche elle est
entrée dans l'union européenne alors là
il ya le parade le parapluie de l'union
européenne serre l'article 42 du traité
sur l'union européenne qui reprend
exactement l'article 5 du traité
atlantique
quand on est attaqué les autres états
membres de l'union européenne doivent
vous défendre donc elle aurait
effectivement en étant mais le salut
nous ramène au sein de l'union
européenne l'est pas non plus dans
l'otan ce que c'est ça alors justement
on va écouter sergueï lavrov le chef de
diplomatie russe on va voir
effectivement que ça va être compliqué
juan
carlos
c'est physique voyaient
fidélisation
des clients donc on voit bien que c'est
toujours la même rhétorique de
dénazification de l'ukraine donc on n'y
ait pas un accord c'est ça qui est
important est inquiétant dans cette
rhétorique russe qui est quand même allé
très loin ce sont les choses sont allées
très loin aussi bien dans la rhétorique
que sur le terrain évidemment avec
toutes ces destructions l'appartement où
on ne parle pas que de neutralité ou
démilitarisation mais on ajoute ce terme
absurde et mais qui volontairement
absurde de dénazification c'est aussi
pour empêcher toute négociation sérieuse
parce qu'à partir du moment où on dit ah
bon on est d'accord là dessus on est
d'accord sur le dombass on est d'accord
sur la reconnaissance même de l'art de
l'annexion de la crimée par la russie on
est d'accord sur toute une série de
choses à partir moscou continue de dire
notre condition absolue c'est la
dénazification de l'ukraine parti au
moment où ça n'a aucune réalité
évitement réels ceux d'en haut sur le
plan politique on discute sur du vide
est ce que ça voudrait dire que en fait
les russes se donne les moyens de
préparer une nouvelle offensive
militaire ça veut dire surtout que pour
le moment on a l'impression qu'ils
négocient non pas pour aboutir à une
solution mais pour gagner du temps il ya
deux ya deux façons de négocier un com
ont comme on le sait soit on négocie pas
ce qu'on veut un accord soit on négocie
parce qu'on veut se laisser du temps
pour pouvoir peut-être d'ailleurs plus
tard on négocier à nouveau mais en
position de force on a l'impression
qu'on est quand même encore aujourd'hui
dans cette situation où les départs
plusieurs personnes odile compris notre
ministre français des affaires
étrangères il ya quelques jours quantité
on a le sentiment que moscou pour le
mans négocie plus pour gagner du temps
que pour aboutir un accord et
appartenant ou à des termes comme ça
comme dénazification qui sont sur la
table c'est très difficile de parler de
choses concrètes c'est qu'on continue à
attaquer pendant ce temps là et on
continue en cercle et mario paul à
meyrin col de fix est ce que c'est ce
qu'il pourrait y avoir une nouvelle
offensive russe justement pendant qu'on
gagne du temps ou bien sûr il est pas
allé au bout de ses objectifs
stratégiques
quand on a aperçu pas tout à fait au
début mai on a perçu au bout de quelques
jours et ses objectifs stratégiques qui
vont bien au delà de la région du
donbass et des deux républiques
russes est ce que c'est ce que vous
dites ce soir parce qu'effectivement on
a parlé ce changement stratégie du côté
des russes qui est maintenant en fait se
focaliserait plutôt sur lèze sur le
donbass mais ça c'était ce n'est un
message qui n'est pas vraiment un
message non je pense que comme bien dire
frédéric charillon là les rues seront un
échec dans ses premiers mois de
l'intervention pour des tas de raisons
qu'on peut analyser sur un peu technique
mais qu'on connaissait et maintenant ils
sont en train de reconstituer leurs
forces parce que poutine ne peut pas
rester sur cet échec même si on a
maintenant ses thuriféraires qui
commençait à dire victoire dans le
donbass on a gagné on à venir en fait il
n'a rien gagné par rapport à ce qu'est
ce qu'ils souhaitaient gagner donc il
est en train de reconstituer ses forces
malheureusement je moi je suis de ceux
qui pensent que malheureusement va
continuer à entourer kiev peut-être
bombardé kiev entouré odessa peut-être
bombardé au dessin en terminer avec
mario paul etc et poursuivre simplement
il faut qu'il complète son dispositif
il est étalé sur plusieurs fronts n'a
pas la maîtrise de l'air il a un système
de commandement on connaît qui négligent
pas qu'un peu compliqué avec beaucoup de
carences il a des gens qui sont pas
forcément des femmes pas leur patrie les
soldats russes ils sont en opération
extérieure même si on leur dit que ce
sont des cousins qu'ils vont défendre
donc n'y a pas cette rage de vaincre cas
le soldat et crânien ou le soldat
français quand six le territoire
français quoi donc je pense que là là on
est dans un temps mort qui a expliqué
frédéric charillon où les rues sont en
train de reconstituer leurs forces
simplement ça va leur prendre du temps
parce qu'ils ont épuisé dans un premier
temps
beaucoup de munitions en particulier de
la munition sophistiqués donc on va
revenir à la veut dire aller à la guerre
d'artillerie et d'obus de dekra secondes
voilà deux choses des choses qui
relèvent de crimes contre la guerre
puisque les crimes de guerre puisque
dans le droit des conflits armés quand
on attaque dépollue populations civiles
au long sermon ce sont des crimes de
guerre lna qu'en pensez vous vous êtes
d'accord avec l'amiral alain kohl de
luffy là dessus est ce qu'il ya une
préparation justement d'une offensive
russe plus fort bon aujourd'hui on
apprend on par le maire dire pin
cueillir pin a été reprise par les
ukrainiens donc on est un petit peu dans
un récit
de résistance très forte des ukrainiens
oui je suis d'autant plus d'accord que
j'ai parlé avec un expert militaire à
moscou très bien informé parce que je
voulais aussi savoir comment interpréter
ce briefing du ministère russe de la
défense lorsqu'ils ont dit on va se
concentrer sur sur la libération du
dombass il faut bien faire attention
avec ce terme de libération puisque non
c'est qu'il s'agit d'une invasion et cet
expert m'a dit que ce que ce qui se
passait maintenant c'était tout à fait
normal par rapport à ce qui s'était
passé avant c'est à dire
qu'effectivement les russes n'ont pas
réussi à mener ce blitzkrieg qu'il
voulait sur kiev au vu des difficultés
qu'on va paru cité mais que l'on connaît
mais que néanmoins l'armée russe garder
l'initiative et que la campagne d'hiver
étant terminée et qu'on étende en cette
mi saison où les sols sont extrêmement
boueux et peu propice aux opérations on
va effectivement se retirer pour se
reconstituer en maintenant la pression
par les bombardements et en relançant
cette offensive j'ajouterai à ce qui a
été dit par rapport au fait que vladimir
poutine se donne du temps il s'agit non
seulement de se donner du temps en
disant qu' il va négocier mais aussi
d'avoir le bon rôle et ça c'est très
important pour bladimir poutine parce
qu'il est dans la construction d'une
image qui appuient cette opération qui
est de dire que les russes sont là pour
justement donc des nazis fier et et de
la cette rhétorique on l'a entendu dans
la bouche de sergueï lavrov mais ont
longtemps à longueur de journée en
russie les russes disent on veut des
nazis pied mais on veut négocier on est
dans une opération de paix et c'est une
nous qui nous qui nous qui nous
positionnons en position de négociateur
alors ce qu'on fasse comme comme vous le
disiez un collègue à moscou 10 et on ne
peut pas avoir un débat d'idée si on
n'est pas d'accord sur les faits on ne
peut pas avoir une négociation si on
n'est pas d'accord sur la réalité de
départ et ce que dit volodymyr zelensky
c'est que nous on veut négocier sur tout
mais on ne veut pas entendre parler de
dénazification et de démilitarisation et
à partir de ce moment là cela permet aux
russes de dire ce sont les ukrainiens
qui ont capoté les négociations
négociations nous serions donc en fait
sur la table pour l'instant on ne peut
pas dire fin est normalement de
négociations en turquie a priori on
n'est pas du tout sur la même longueur
d'onde ce dialogue de sourds se souvenir
de ce qui s'est passé avec avec le
conflit local qui était le dombass et
les accords de minsk il y a eu des
accords de cessez le feu et de paie
finalement qui ont été adoptées dès 2014
et des demies 14 la russie n'a eu de
cesse de dire ce sont les ukrainiens qui
ont fait capoter ces accords en disant
même que les rues ce n'était même pas
partie prenante du conflit donc
effectivement on est dans une réalité
complètement parallèle et à partir de ce
moment là vladimir poutine peut dire
absolument tous les jours que il veut
négocier et que les ukrainiens bloque
les négociations
il parviendra à ses fins par la voie
militaire et non pas par les
négociations qui elle pourrait mener
seulement à des accords de cessez-le-feu
local de retrait des armes de la n2
front haut du couloir humanitaire fin
des choses finalement assez l'intérieur
ça veut dire que c'est le terrain qui va
déterminer même l'issue de ces
négociations ou même le dire est ce
qu'on peut mettre sur la table toutes
façons il est clair que aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment là j'allais dire la
parole aux militaires que donc cette
cette tentative de négociation
évidemment il faut l'encourager on veut
tous la paix on veut que des corridors
humanitaires on veut que l'aide
humanitaire puisse parvenir on veut le
cessez le feu donc on ne peut qu'espérer
que ces pourparlers en turquie puisse
conduire à quelque chose sa vie et aussi
d'autres initiatives on a parlé d'israël
aussi bon il ya le président macro
mandanda devait téléphoner à cet effet
pour des questions humanitaires avaient
tous présents poutine avec la nature qui
également y voir la grèce pour faciliter
des opérations humanitaires mario paul
donc tout ça est évidemment bienvenus
mais en même temps on voit bien que
c'est toujours les guerres des
bombardements et la partie russe n'a pas
l'intention d'interrompre ses activités
militaires
donc on ne peut qu'espérer qu'ils tepco
débouche quelque chose il faut pas non
plus s'illusionner juste tout à fait
d'accord avec les prés opinant ça risque
de durer encore longtemps
malheureusement volet pour les citoyens
ukrainiens amiral vous êtes d'accord
avec ça ça va durer encore longtemps
l'affrontement purement militaire c'est
le terrain qui guide le reste alors non
pas exactement sont les politiques qui
guident l'affrontement militaire pas se
tromper de haut parce trompé l'oeil d'un
paradigme s'il voulait mais ça va se
traduire mécaniquement par des
affrontements militaires qui seront
contrôlés parce qu'on va pas arriver aux
extrêmes sans doute pas et tant que les
russes n'auront pas la maîtrise du ciel
n'ont pas la maîtrise d'un certain
nombre d'actes de communication devront
d'être difficultés de communication
eh bien on va avoir comme on l'a vu
aujourd'hui des petites contre attaque
c'est pas la contre-offensive
ukrainienne mais sur des points faibles
rien pour marquer les esprits les
ukrainiens vont faire des petites contre
attaque et là on est dans un processus
qui peut durer pendant des semaines et
des semaines voilà qui ne sera arrêté
que par la négociation un accord un
cessez le feu il ya un autre choix un
autre point soit quelle présence de
l'ass qui a parlé c'est que tout ça ne
peut être validée par un référendum il
avait répété déjà il ya quelques jours
donc évidemment il négocie mais c'est le
peuple ukrainien au bout du compte qui
décidera donc c'est important de le
rappeler donc ils s'engagent dans des
négociations mais il rappelle que c'est
le peuple ukrainien qui décidera on va
revenir sur la visite de joe biden à
varsovie 1 c'était ce week-end le
président américain samedi dernier s'en
est pris violemment à vladimir poutine
il l'a qualifié de boucher et surtout il
a jugé qu'il ne pouvait pas rester au
pouvoir après son invasion de l'ukraine
on écoute
et on vous dira qu anthony blinken donc
le chef de la diplomatie a nuancé très
rapidement les propos du président on
écoute
rédaction comment vous appelez ça c'est
une bourde cesse justifie d'un point de
vue moral mais on ne fait pas de la
politique de cette manière là ça a
suscité beaucoup d'émotion ça suscitait
un rétropédalage de la maison fin de
blink est lui même ça a suscité des
prises de distance on va dire des alliés
européens y compris de la france quand
notre président à un public est là qu on
dise ces changements pourraient pas ces
mots là donc oui on a le sentiment qu'il
ya une erreur en même temps c'était fait
devant un public
polonais en l'occurrence qui est assez
acquis à 7 à cette rhétorique très durs
contre contre poutine il ya aussi en
europe centrale et orientale des
populations qui qui ont très peur de
deux là demir poutine donc pour eux ça
résonne à leurs oreilles quand même
comme quelque chose de rassurant
d'entendre le président américain durcir
le ton à présent américain que d'autres
avaient accusé un petit peu un petit peu
trop trop faible un petit peu trop mou
et puis c'est vrai qu'on peut se poser
la question de savoir si c'était préparé
six est sorti tout seul joe biden avait
on a fait quelques autres être une
sortie toute seule fois peut être une
gaffe disons qu'il a il nous a habitués
à quelques dents dans le passé plus
lointain est traître gaffeur sur le plan
plus international et depuis donc c'est
une gaffe je ne le sais pas c'est comme
la sphère de taiwan dont vous quand
jeanne est comment vous l'analysez pour
vous c'est une gaffe que les états unis
qu'à table
et on a l'impression que c'est une gaffe
un oui mais c'est pas sûr parce que
pourtant il ya une fonction à la gaffe
pour taiwan quand il avait dit oui on
défendrait taiwan si il y avait un
problème est là aussi son entourage est
un petit peu sursauter ça rassure en
même temps un public il ya toujours une
fonction à lagrave psychologiquement
c'est vrai justement il se rappelait que
juste avant l'invasion russe il avait
dit quelque chose comme
même s'il ya des un engrenage entre de
violence entre la russie et l'ukraine
nous n'interviendrons pas alors on s'est
beaucoup interrogé on aura est ce que
c'est la peine de le dire est-ce qui ne
valait mieux pas laisser en suspens
évidemment on n'est pas intervenue
l'article 5 de l'otan de ce qu'il avait
dit déjà clairement
veut dire aussi clairement voilà boucher
et il faut il peut pas et poutine peut
pas rester c'est deux choses des deux
choses différentes bien sûr le boucher
on peut dire un président ne devrait pas
parler comme ça mais en même temps on
peut lire maladie mais ça c'est ce que
disent les russes mais on peut dire
aussi aux risques à président ne devrait
pas non plus traiter de drogués nazis et
les régimes notre pays en revanche là
l'idée de dire il peut pas rester au
footy ne veut pas rester boire ça fait
resurgir tout le spectre de tout ce que
tout le change et du sud reproche à
l'occident depuis des années c'était
effectivement le fameux walk in chains
changement de régime comme on l'a vu en
irak
alors il avait déjà dit que c'est un
assassin killer il l'avait dit et vous
souvenez c'était de deux trois mois
après son entrée en fonction et quelques
mois après il rencontrait monsieur
poutine à genève pour des négociations
importantes elena ce que cette phrase
peut alimenter la rhétorique justement
un peu paranoïaque du régime russe où tu
as fait alors j'allais le dire donc
effectivement vladimir poutine je pense
n'a aucun problème avec le fait de se
faire traiter de boucher par joe biden
je pense même que quelque part il aime
ça parce qu'ils n'ont pas ce qu'il il
aime le rapport de force il respecte le
rapport de force il n'entend que le
rapport de forces est effectivement
après que joe biden a répondu lors de
cette interview pensez vous que poutine
est un killer est un assassin il a
répondu oui vladimir poutine avait
rétorqué c'est celui qui dit qui est il
était ensuite copains comme cochons et
se rencontrer à genève donc l'avenir
poutine n'a pas de pros bon j'exagère
mais mme effectivement vladimir poutine
n'a pas respecte ce rapport de force et
donc il il a ensuite rencontré joe biden
comme quelqu'un qui est à son échelle
qui à sa hauteur pour pouvoir parler
avec lui ensuite effectivement cette
histoire de il ne peut pas rester au
pouvoir ça c'est vraiment de l'eau au
moulin de vladimir poutine et de sa
propagande qui dit voilà vous les
occidentaux et les états unis vous
chercher par tous les moyens à nous
dominer à dominer le monde à détruire la
russie il a été reproché tout durant
toutes ces années aux états unis par par
vladimir poutine depuis la montée de la
confrontation en 2012 cela n'a de cela
ne date pas de maintenant de d'avoir
renversé d'avoir renversé kadhafi
d'avoir tenté de renverser le régime
légitime selon la propagande russe de
bachar al assad d'avoir renversé saddam
hussein donc vraiment ça ça ne date pas
d'hier et vladimir poutine a en horreur
justement les révolutions de couleurs
qui serait selon lui instrumentalisés
par l'étranger pour ensuite renversé des
pouvoirs légitimes et ça vraiment
vladimir poutine peut-être que quelque
part il en a peur mais en tout cas c'est
clair que lorsque joe biden dit ça
ensuite s'est repris en masse en russie
pour dire vous voyez c'est eux qui
veulent nous attaquer c'est eux qui
veulent nous détruire la mairie c'est
précisément la russie qui veut un réel
changement de régime en ukraine alors
qu'il a été élu louis et dans as well as
raison ce centre est est ce que si on va
juger sans doute cette rhétorique
l'ukraine c'est le terrain de jeu des
états unis on entend des mots dans la
propagande comme l'ukraine les états
unis veulent
voyez l'ukraine dans le sang pour
atteindre leurs objectifs de destruction
de la russie passe est un délire
paranoïaque qui va très très loin qu'ils
oublient qu'ils attaquent et le premier
qui fait la guerre pour avoir la paix
mais effectivement ça c'est vraiment ça
nourrit ça nourrit la justification
finalement de vladimir poutine de sa
gamme amiral vous êtes d'accord est ce
que c'est une gaffe parce que pourquoi
est-ce qu'il a prononcée telmo joe biden
moi je vous ferai part simplement mon
expérience
des niveaux à deux rencontres avec des
dirigeants américains russes chinois je
fais partie du comité stratégique
franco-chinois ya quelques années et
c'est ce sont des pays
à prendre les américains les russes qui
ne connaissent qu'un langage brutal que
des rapports de force selon lui tout le
temps on le voit toujours du côté russe
on le voit rarement du côté américain
les diplomates américains les dirigeants
américains les militaires américains un
vocabulaire de force et de rapport de
force donc là il est vraisemblable que
ben laden est un peu gaffe et en parlant
de ça je parle pas de la gaffe sur le
régime mais en sortant le mot de boucher
mais c'est comme je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous c'est un mot que les
dirigeants américains département d'état
au pentagone utilisent et que c'est le
seul bouc que poutine reconnaît quand on
est amoché quand on est un petit peu mou
face à lui il a aucune considération
c'est pareil avec les chinois et quand
il dit justement qu'il ne pouvait pas
rester au pouvoir c'est ça qui est fait
vraiment polémique amiral oui mais ça
c'est alors là c'est peu c'est une gaffe
c'est une gaffe et je pense que c'est
pas vous dit que c'est une gaffe parce
que
c'est pas le moment de parler de ce
genre de choses en tout cas et c'est pas
le lieu même si on était en pologne avec
comme l'a rappelé faire des crayons les
polonais ne faut pas oublier que dans le
les expatriés aux etats-unis en tout cas
les immigrés aux états unis vous avez
une forte proportion de grands patrons
qui viennent de pologne de géorgie de
roumanie etc même al amal braque et qui
sont pas des tendres est qui et qui
encourage ce genre de propos et qui
encourage ce genre en deux et donc la
linguistique l'escaladent la rupture des
relations diplomatiques
non non non non non ils sont trop non à
l'otan si tu as rétropédalage
les grands les ficelles
les grands savent se parler il ya
toujours un canal qui reste on est pas
on est avec des gens qui ont des
puissances se détruire depuis très
longtemps et qui savent se parler mais
ça n'empêche pas que le discours soit
terriblement offensif rude rugueuse et
parfois un petit peu au hors limites
qu'on va en limite c'est à dire est
qu'il attend aussi la perche ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure il ya une fonction
c'est peut-être une gaffe même temps
s'est posé sur la table et il n'est pas
impossible non plus qu'en russie la
question de l'après poutine 20 finissent
par se poser d'abord biologiquement et
ensuite parce que ça fait plus de vingt
ans qu'il est qu'il est au pouvoir et
puis parce qu'on peut imaginer et lui
même plat des meilleures poutines ça qui
peut être important peut-être aussi
commencé à se dire que si cette
opération est vraiment un échec et
militaires et est conduit l isolement
économique et diplomatique de la russie
autour de lui il peut y avoir dans
l'appareil d'état russe des gens qui
finirait par se dire que finalement il
est peut-être temps de passer à autre
chose et m il ya aussi il ya aussi ça
derrière ça veut pas dire que ça mais
lui il va venir plus il peut aussi
utiliser ça on n'en voyez bien vous
voyez comment sont les américains ils
n'ont pas changé c'est là où yahoo yaga
même temps ça plante si vous de la
graine ne dira poutine n'est pas éternel
vous êtes d'accord lna avec ça ça fait
parce que d'abord je ne vois pas qui
aujourd'hui pourrait s'opposer à aplanir
poutine qui semblent diriger absolument
seul et on voit que même si on n'a pas
vraiment accès à ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur mais on sent qu'il n'y a
personne aujourd'hui pour le freiner
ensuite vladimir poutine n'est pas
seulement vladimir poutine vladimir
poutine c'est un système c'est un
système qui perdure qui a qui a basculé
à la chute de l'union soviétique avec
ses années de chaos mais qui ensuite
très vite retourné sur les rails avec
aujourd'hui un pays qu'ils dirigeaient
par le pilier que sont les services
secrets russes qu'est le fsb qui est un
non seulement a mérité mais 1 mais
quelqu'un qui perpétue absolument toutes
les méthodes qui fait renaître
aujourd'hui les méthodes du kgb pendant
l'époque soviétique est donc finalement
sans parler même d'opposition ou de deux
personnes qui pourraient
constituer un
carnet une opposition parce qu'on sait
que le principal opposant alexeï navalni
il est aujourd'hui en prison il vient
d'être condamné à neuf années
supplémentaires de prison mais même dans
l'entourage de vladimir poutine moi je
ne vois personne il ne serait pas le
représentant parfait est l'héritier
finalement de ce système qui perdure
depuis l'opposition gars en ukraine mais
il y a eu des oppositions mais des
défections c'est des gens qui partent
directement à l'étranger c'est des gens
qui fuient directement à l'étranger et
puis ce n'est pas le premier cercle si
vous voulez ce son voile à on a vu des
oligarques on a vu des artistes on a vu
des ça veut dire qu'il est
indéboulonnable ben pour le moment en
tout cas il paraît complètement
indéboulonnable je vois même pas les
oligarques qui pourrait s'opposer à lui
parce que finalement même le système
aujourd'hui ne repose pas sur sur les
oligarques le système repose
véritablement sur les services secrets
sur le blog sécuritaire comme on dit il
vaut trio je suis assez d'accord c'est
très difficile de faire des pronostics
ceci dit juste une toute petite nuance
par rapport ce que vous avez dit tout à
fait la grèce que vous avez indiquée
mais en géopolitique je parle devant un
professeur de géopolitique
il ya souvent il ya parfois des
événements qu'on n'a pas prévu à la
chute du mur de berlin n'était pas
vraiment programmé encore que dans les
mois qui ont précédé donc voilà il peut
se passer des choses on n'en sait rien
donc c'est pour ça on peut s'amuser à
faire des scénarii non mais ne l'y faut
pas l'écarter
fatalement mais on ne sait pas quand
comment et voilà quel moment il ya deux
choses il ya l'objectivité de la
situation qui fait qu'effectivement il
peut penser que la lumière poutine tient
les choses dans la pierre et à la
perception de vladimir poutine lui qui
est dedans comme dans tout système
autoritaire est un homme très seul parce
que comme vous l'avez dit il dirige et
dirige seul donc ça ne m'empêche pas
d'avoir peur de da chaque fois d'un
d'opposants etc c'est vrai c'est deux
choses différentes il ya une expression
en russie qui dit être à la mangeoire ça
veut dire que tous les toutes les
toutous les gens qui entourent vladimir
poutine aujourd'hui ce sont des gens qui
se nourrissent de ce système qui n'ont
finalement pas besoin de plus on a vu
passer dans forbes des papiers qui
disait que les oligarques était en train
de perdre des milliards mais finalement
ce n'est pas très grave parce que la
russie c'est une économie de rente et
c'est aussi une économie qui peut
tourner à l'intérieur de son propre
système et on l'a vu que ça a marché
pendant soixante dix ans cette histoire
donc finalement effectivement vous avez
tout à fait raison de dire qu'il peut y
avoir des imprévus mais en tout cas de
autre position à nous aujourd'hui de ce
que l'on observe et de ce que l'on vit
surtout à l'intérieur quand on est en
russie dans ce régime parce que nous on
regarde les choses de l'extérieur et n'a
envie de se raccrocher à des bouées de
sauvetage et d'être un petit peu
optimiste mais regardez ce qui a précédé
cette invasion de l'ukraine regardez ce
qui s'est passé en décembre dernier mois
en dix ans de correspondance je vais à
couvrir l'événement le plus triste et
pourtant j'en ai vu des choses tristes
mais j'ai eu à couvrir l'événement le
plus triste qui a été la liquidation de
cette ong mémorial qui essayait de
finalement de restaurer de réécrire une
histoire sanguinaire de l'union
soviétique qui n'a jamais été écrite en
restaurant ne serait-ce que le nombre et
les noms des morts du régime de staline
et cette ong a été liquidée dans
l'indifférence je dirais relativement
quasi générale parce que le régime de
vladimir poutine de déranger jusqu'à
présent personne alors c'est vous dire
que si en occident cela ne dérangeait
pas et cela pouvait perdurer tant qu'il
n'a pas menacé l'europe d'une guerre est
bien à l'intérieur de la russie
aujourd'hui les gens qui se nourrissent
de ce système et qui sont à l'intérieur
de ce système n'ont absolument pas
intérêt à ce que ces système s'effondre
mais je suis d'accord avec vous mais on
a connu aussi d aider des régimes très
très dictatoriaux et très dur où on
pouvait changer un homme sans changer le
système on disait à peu près la même
chose je dis pas que je pense que vous
avez raison je ne dis pas qu
actuellement vladimir poutine voit son
pouvoir menacé mais rappelons-nous
nubarak rappelons-nous devais de benali
rappelons nous des printemps on disait
la même chose vous et c'est un système
un système de rente il ya des cas où
rien n'a changé un potentiel de
révolution à l'intérieur du pays et de
2,2 de gens qui pouvaient se rebeller ne
serait ce que dans leur esprit
aujourd'hui vous avez on en parlait tout
à l'heure dans ma chronique les sondages
officiels qui donne 80 % de popularité à
bladimir tout et ce sont les opposants
vous le disais les heureuses ans ont
tous critiqué que paye alors on va tout
de suite à kiev justement retrouver
gilbert craag puisqu'on l'a raté en
début d'émission gulliver bonsoir je
pense que la liaison est maintenant
bonne est-ce que vous m'entendez
oui là je suis revenu à l'intérieur
parce qu'apparemment sur le balcon la
connexion n'étaient pas assez bonnes
donc le jeu vous racontez nous ce qui se
passe à irbine parce qu'on en parlait au
tout début de l'émission
ah oui d'abord je voulais vous dire même
s'il probablement ça va sans dire mais
disons le camp même que les ukrainiens
tout cas je pense que dans leur
écrasante majorité ils ne se sentiront
pas en sécurité tant que vladimir
poutine sera au pouvoir en russie et ils
étaient ils se sont réjouis des propos
de joe biden après est-ce que c'était le
bon moment de le dire et tous ces
nuances là en tout cas c'était c'est
quelque chose qui pour l'ukraine je
pense est une question vitale ils
peuvent pas s'imaginer un avenir où
vladimir poutine serait en cours ce
serait encore au pouvoir pour ce qui est
de la situation sur le terrain oui
justement ils ont repris y repine
apparemment c'est le maire qui le
confirme je pense qu'il est encore des
combattants russes dans la ville des
opérations de nettoyage sont prévues
pour demain et les jours qui suivent il
ne sera toujours interdite pour les
séries civile de revenir dans here pin
et je pense pendant plusieurs jours
encore ce sera très contrôlé ivre pin's
étaient soixante mille habitants qui ont
presque tous étaient évacués ceux qui
ceux qui n'ont pas péri dans les combats
et c'est une victoire pour ses contres
offensif ukrainienne qui domine dans le
nord autour de kiev est aussi dans le
sud il ya des contre offensives mais le
porte parole des militaires ukrainien
l'a dit clairement aujourd'hui même si
pour le moment celle offensif uniquement
dans le dock d'albas la défense contre
les contre offensives ukrainien dans
d'autres endroits du pays et le
regroupement en russie et en biélorussie
les ukrainiens ne crois pas du tout à
cette annonce des russes comme quoi il
allait se concentrer uniquement sur le
dos de baston leurs opérations dans les
semaines à venir ils redoutent que après
le regroupement ils vont à nouveau
tenter d'encercler ou même de prendre
les villes principales du cren comme
motif ou actifs donc on peut croire que
dans le cadre d'une nouvelle offensive
russe peut-être que irin sera encore
ciblé par l'armée russe donc on ne peut
pas considérer que que cette ville peut
maintenant se reposer se sentir en
sécurité
amiral donc le jeu vous êtes d'accord
avec cela si on se plonge son a dit à
l'ats mario paul peut-être un mot sur
cette ville qui ont vraiment la ville
meurtrie ya en ce moment 2 d'ukraine et
puis sur toute cette partie sud vous qui
connaissez bien en plus ces opérations
amphibies et qu'est ce que ça représente
stratégiquement non marioupol
représente pas grand chose parce que la
mer d'azov est fermée elle est entourée
de deux territoires russes donc on va
complètement fermée marioupol c'est
symbolique donc il faut détruire
continue à détruire etc en revanche
odessa et la prise de la prise d'eau des
salles un an pêcheries l'ukraine d'avoir
un commerce extérieur un peu plus tard
dont on sait pas quelle configuration et
de permettrait à
poutine de contrôler tout le flanc nord
de la mer noire mais n'oublions pas que
la mer noire élevée dont on a peu parlé
c'est aussi une mère où il ya du gaz au
nord de la turquie il ya des anges il ya
des enjeux pétrole et gaz de mémoire
c'est davantage du gaz et là on est en
phase de conflits potentiels avec deux
pays de l'otan qui bordent ivoire de
flores de la mer n'a donc on n'est pas
sorti de de difficultés à caractère
militaro politico économique et même si
on est maintenant on est focalisé par le
renforcement des russes par la mer et
par odessa n'est pas terminée moi je
crois pas une opération amphibie c'est
un peu compliqué puis le terrain s'y
prête pas en revanche ils vont certes
certainement prendre possession du port
de façon à débarquer par centaines de
tonnes de matériel et par centaines
d'hommes des hommes pour remonter sur le
flanc sud ça c'est tout à fait possible
à partir de la crimée enfin le crime est
donc d'arriver à apprendre odessa ce que
oui voilà mesdames mais pas par une opa
pour prendre votre autre comparaison que
n'avait pas fait le débarquement de
normandie ça c'est pas sympa pas la mer
et au nez ça que s'il apporte à la
transnistrie mais alors après il ya des
milliers de croix 3000 ou 4000 russes
qui sont installés là depuis 1991 et qui
occupe une illégalement une partie de la
moldavie donc voilà on est là pour le
coup on s'approche de la roumanie et la
bulgarie elena cod sage tu as déjà rodé
ça oui moi je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord sur marioupol et le manque
d'importance de marioupol parce que d'un
point de vue j'ai dicté chambaud l'icm
et autres au point de vue stratégique
voilà c'était d'un point de vue
stratégique cela permet de rallier la
crimée aussi par la terre et de créer ce
fameux couloir mais en tout cas mes
sources para militaires russes me parle
dès le départ de marioupol comme étant
vraiment pas négociable est d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui on voit que effectivement
tous les efforts se concentrent sur
cette ville lorsqu'on écoute notamment
alors j'en reviens toujours à ça parce
que c'est quand même très important
l'après la propagande des chaînes de
télévision russes marioupol se situe
déjà en république populaire
autoproclamé de données est ce parce que
revenons aussi à ce qu'a dit vladimir
poutine le 22 février l'un des objectifs
de départ cela ne sera certainement pas
le seul mais ces deux restent d'abord il
a commencé cette opération en
reconnaissant les républiques populaires
autoproclamé de donetsk de lougansk est
curieusement n'avait jamais même été
reconnue par la russie depuis l'invasion
en 2014 et donc il a reconnu en dix ans
elles doivent exister dans les
frontières inscrits dans leur
constitution voilà les oblasts donc
c'est à dire les régions administratives
de départ dans lesquelles il était en
ukraine et marioupol en fait partie et
aussi là où symboliquement et vous avez
raison c'est absolument important c'est
parce qu'au tout début de la guerre du
pôle avait été prise par ce qu'on
appelait toujours un peu à tort les
séparatistes pro russes avec l'appui des
mercenaires et puis aussi quelque part
des éléments de l'armée régulière russe
donc mario a été ensuite elle a été
reprise de nouveau par les ukrainiens et
donc ça c'est vous dire si vladimir
poutine n'aime pas perdre c'est à dire
c'est aussi reprendre aujourd'hui ce qui
nous appartiendrait de droits parce que
on l'a gagnée militairement au départ
fera ce qu'on pourrait terminer par
finalement ça pourrait se terminer par
une partition du pays on a beaucoup
parlé de la partition est ouest avec le
fleuve gnat pro débuts au début au
milieu oui à partir du moment où on
discute déjà du statut des républiques
russophones de l'est forcément c'est
quelque chose qui est sur la table après
tout va dépendre de tous les russes
veulent placer là bas parce que bon la
crimée c'est de fait yahia un fait
accompli depuis maintenant plusieurs
années ça peut ça peut revenir sur la
table ça reconnaissait reconnaissez ce
référendum reconnaissait l'annexion et
ça ça serait un point il ya ensuite les
républiques de l'est du pays et là aussi
le président ukrainien avait déjà laissé
entendre que ça pouvait aussi se
discuter nancy la russie souhaite
vraiment un contrôle une continuité
territoriale qui englobe tout le toute
la façade maritime de la mer noire qui
englobe odessa qu'ils fassent la
jonction comme on le faisait tout à
l'heure avec la transnistrie voir
effectivement autour du autour du
jusqu'au fleuve ça va devenir très
difficile parce que autant je pense que
beaucoup de parties prenantes
aujourd'hui sont prêtes à discuter de
d'enjeux territoriaux pour mettre fin à
cette guerre autant il ya une ligne qui
ne faut pas franchir pour ne pas donner
le sentiment là je parle du point de vue
aussi des occidentaux que finalement le
fait accompli et la politique
d'agression est payante il serait lui
aussi à pascal au cas ça serait le cas
avec aussi relever c'est que les russes
penser que l'est l'ukraine russophone et
russophile qu'il fallait distinguer sa
de l'ouest plus proche de l'union
européenne or c'est pas vrai on a vu des
grandes villes russophone comme kharkiv
je me suis rendu une fois eh bien il ya
une résistance là aussi donc
c'est le caire cette guerre en fait à
ressouder toutou l'ukraine est et ouest
ensemble un contrôle russe sur ces
territoires là ne serait pas du tout
gagné haut la russie parce qu'elle
pourrait à ce moment-là tomber dans
autre chose qui serait une situation de
guérilla ou d'insurrection permanente
guy l'hiver ça me paraît peu probable
justement une partition de l'ukraine
entre l'est et l'ouest même si ça
paraissait être sur la table à un moment
donné
en tout cas je pense que le nombre
d'ukrainiens dans l'est qui ne veulent
pas vivre sous domination russe à mon
augmenter drastiquement depuis le début
de l'invasion j'ai parlé à des personnes
que je connaissais dans le donbass qui
avaient des attitudes plutôt pro-russe
ou en tout cas n'aimait pas beaucoup
l'armée ukrainienne n'avait pas beaucoup
le pouvoir des pièges c'était le moins
qu'on puisse dire quand je les appelais
depuis l'invasion ils disent que pour
beaucoup d'entre eux en tout cas ils ont
ouvert les yeux ils ont compris
maintenant ils soutiennent l'armée
ukrainienne et qui pense que la seule
chose à faire c'est de défendre le pays
l on l'a dit mais tu n'as vraiment
contribué à réduire de manière
extraordinairement vite le soutien à la
russie y compris en ukraine de l'efs
merci beaucoup guy l'hiver merci à vous
amiral alors qu'al de fille mercy et
frédéric charillon merci lna et merci à
vous doutriaux merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivi avec nous sur france 24
[Musique]